there's five stages to death right if
the first is denial
the last one is acceptance I pretty much
went from denial straight to it straight
to it I got stabbed again because this
is only six weeks after the terrorist
attack right so very close together and
I just go okay I'm gonna die so pretty
much right when that happens we became
international heroes overnight our life
totally changed you know like I'm
sitting in the hospital and the u.s.
embassy people got there and the first
thing he says to me is to say you better
get ready the president's calling you in
like ten minutes and I was like what
like you know I didn't realize it was
that big of a deal like I knew it was a
big deal but I was like is it really
that big of a deal the president's gonna
call me and so that you know we're all
of a sudden on this like big military
kind of like tour going on all the talk
shows I went on Jimmy Kimmel show he
gave me a Camaro you know like so we're
just like dude like the craziest things
are
gave me a damn car he's a good guy and I
was I always give my friend Anthony [ __ ]
because he chose to go on the Jimmy
Fallon show and he gave him a slipper I
was like but so so right we go on this
big tour right and it's kind of like
okay back to reality I go back to my
normal life that was fun but it's over
and I go back to Sacramento and I
decided to take a few days off to hang
out with some of my friends in sac I
hadn't seen him in a while so I wanted
to go out with them you know go drinking
and stuff and so we go out to a club and
it's me like three girls I've known
since I was like 16 years old and
another guy that I had just met he's
like a new boyfriend and one of the
girls I was with long story short or at
the club one of the girls starts
throwing up so it's a guy who you know I
was like alright we're getting out of
here this is over it's a [ __ ] show so
we're outside at this point she's down
on the sidewalk we're just kind of like
making sure she's all right and then the
dude the other guy that was there says
Larry I'm gonna go grab the card you
know I was like all right cool I'll wait
here with them see you in five minutes
he goes to get the car and then five
guys and a couple of other girls walked
by and a few of them ended up being a
part of this Asian gang called hop sing
and they're ran out of San Francisco and
they take out their phone like their
snapchat and they start recording her
like a she's like dry heaving on the
sidewalk so I was like hey man like what
are you you know just being the only guy
that what the [ __ ] are you doing like
get out of here and then that of course
you know escalated into an argument
they're yelling I was yelling then the
girls I'm with start yelling everybody's
yelling at each other and it's like but
there was a moment where I was like okay
there's five of them there's one of me
I'm gonna have to fight them all if this
happens I was like maybe I need to
de-escalate this like everybody relax so
like now I'm trying to just you know
bring it down and I'm like pushing one
of the girls I'm with back and the dudes
on my back out of nowhere he jumps over
my show
boom she gets hit square in the face I'm
surprised she get her teeth knocked out
so I see her face just go blue it just
get blasted right in front of me and I
just turn around and then I start
swinging and I still had my cast on from
my hand surgery so I only got one arm
and I'm just punching punch and punch
and as soon as I throw a punch they're
all on me
I'm trapped against this wall pretty
much and you're just a natural hero so
he so I'm trapped against this wall and
I'm just thinking alright Spencer like
just don't fall down so I'm gonna get
stomped out yeah so just stay up on your
feet and I'm like I need to get away
from this wall I bust out of the wall
and I'm backing up into the middle of
Street and I'm talking to hell oh [ __ ]
at this point I'm like what's up come on
like I'm he keeps walking towards me and
I'm like one of the drugs all of them
all of them are still coming at me and
I'm in the middle of street hoping a car
comes and runs them over to me and I so
I gotta bait one of the guys to get a
little closer to me I drop him but he
didn't I didn't knock him out but I
figured at this point I got trying to
knock them all out cuz they're they're
following me you know at this point so I
got to do something
I go to basically try and finish him
while he's on the ground and then as I
hit him on the ground his friend comes
up behind me and stabs me in the back
like an inch and a half away from my
spinal cord and that's the one that's
the only one I felt at that point I turn
around and I square up with him just
because I said in my head too I was like
oh he just stabbed me I turn around I
look and I see he has the knife down by
his side like this and we're just kind
of bouncing back and forth and I just go
whoa man like chill out and I just run
down the street and then I'm run down
the street I'm just thinking that Matt a
shape or something and I'm just going
yeah yeah bullets but that one didn't
but I realize I had been stabbed four
times total whoa yeah they're trying to
kill you oh yeah a hundred percent I
looked down I just see blood I was
wearing a white t-shirt so I see blood
blood blood and then all of my whole
body just goes like it's like a massive
cramp just like it just set in and they
collapsed my lung he punctured my heart
my nicked my liver and then like the one
in my back was more of a flesh wound
they missed all my nerves but thank
goodness I walk down the street my
friends come up to me a cab driver comes
out to me first and he says a man you
want me to key the hospital I was like I
just just just call 9-1-1 like I'm not
trying to die in the back of a cab you
know hey I kind of walked down the
street and my friends come up to me like
oh you know it's just like a movie scene
I late I started to get dizzy so I'm
like I need to lay down on the ground
and I'm so [ __ ] scared I [ __ ] that
way in the ground that's it was he was
well it was scary but in the weirdest
way there's five stages to death all
right you're the first is denial
the last one is acceptance I pretty much
went from denial straight to it straight
to acceptance I got stabbed again
because this is only six weeks after the
terrorist attack right so very close
together and I just go okay I'm gonna
die like I see how much blood I'm losing
I can't breathe and my whole body is
just cramping up and so I lay down on
the ground and they're all my friends
come over me and they're like you know
they were panicking of course and I just
pretty much said like hey just tell my
mom my brother my sister I love him it's
gonna be all right
and then I closed my eyes and thought I
died and then I woke up to the paramedic
giving me a sternum rub and then whisked
me in the ambulance I was a six minute
ride to a level 1 trauma center I had
open-heart surgery exploratory surgery
bilateral chest - some weird funky tube
in my stomach but you know luckily all
the wounds were
they didn't damage my organs too much
and so the doctor pretty much told me
I'm going to make a hundred percent
recovery and so here I am
Wow that's what I always say is that the
perspective I have on life now is
priceless because when I when I laid
down it and I was like all right I'm
gonna die like it was almost like I was
like this weird calmness came over me
like I was almost ready to die but I
wasn't at the same time and when I woke
up in the hospital actually this is what
really changed me like I felt like I
hadn't really like processed a lot what
was going on in my life because
especially because it all happened at
once and I was just sitting in there and
this is right after the doctor told me I
was gonna make a hundred percent
recovery and I start hearing this guy
and then in the room next door to me
died and you know you're an Icee use of
people were dying in there all the time
but I listened to the whole thing his
family's there is his dad's punching the
wall you know screaming his name telling
him to wake up wake up and so I'm just
sitting here listening to the whole
thing my nurse comes in and I know I
kind of play stupid I'm like hey what
happened over there and it was like oh
we just had someone die I said oh what'd
he die of
he said pneumonia and I was like okay
kind of like expecting him to be a lot
older you know and I said how old was he
he said oh he was 18 years old so an 18
year old died of pneumonia in the room
next door to me and I survived a
terrorist attack six weeks ago now I
just got literally stabbed in the heart
and somehow I'm gonna make a hundred
percent recovery that's why I just broke
down in tears started crying like I was
like what am I still doing here like it
just didn't make sense to me at the time
and it still kind of doesn't at times
you know it's like what why was I spared
and given a healthy body post everything
and this young man over here is just
dying in ammonia in a hospital so my
perspective on life is it's completely
different than I wanted then what it was
before and something you can't buy so
I'm really appreciative to have it at
such a young age and it's just like man
literally you don't know when your
time's coming it's gonna happen when you
least expect it and now really I just
try to do the most with myself and just
try and affect the other people's lives
as much as I came and I feel like the
best way I can do that is just by
telling my story and just sharing my
life with people and I just hope man I
can kind of like stealing the line from
the movie with Tom Hanks Saving Private
Ryan at the end when he says earned this
like I feel like I need to earn the life
I've been given because I feel like I've
been spared so it's a privilege to be
alive so I just have a deep appreciation
for what happened to me because what
happened to me supposed to be you know
one of the worst things to ever happen
to somebody but it ended up almost being
the best thing that ever happened to me
you're kind of like the silver lining
the only one guy went to prison he's
serving nine years but that for
attempted murder assault with a deadly
weapon and great bodily harm he got nine
years so I feel like it could have been
longer but I forgive to do too we all do
stupid [ __ ] so I can't just sit here mad
at him for the rest of my life you know
that's gonna do nothing but hurt me so I
forgive the guy I hope I hope he gets
out of prison and I hope he does
something positive with his life thank
you for sharing that
now of course cried on the pod you have
okay I didn't know this man I'm sorry no
dude thank you thank you I'm filled with
[ __ ] inspiration makes man life and
energy I know that [ __ ] man it's um
amazing dude that is amazing so that was
in 2015 that was all in 2015
yeah and then pretty much right after
that we went into we wrote the book
while I was recovering and we published
our book on our life stories and like me
me Alec and Anthony just how our
friendship overall and how like we felt
like our whole life was a preparation
for the day of the terrorist attack and
just like how everything went our way
that day and everything like that and so
we had post we had published the book a
year and a week after the anniversary of
the attack and during that time - we met
Clint Eastwood in an award show the guys
choice Spike TV award show he was given
us the Hero Award and so like we knew
like you know that was the whole goal of
us writing the book was like now
hopefully this gets turned into a movie
one day or something you know and not
thinking would ever actually happen and
we were like we're oh [ __ ] like we're
mean Clint Eastwood like this is what he
does up his alley like he makes real
life story movies we have to say
something to him even if it's a joke you
know and so we go back to the green room
and you know we're just kind of shooting
the [ __ ] with them he's a real cool guy
super funny and were just like hey you
know way we're writing a book right now
it's coming out in August like hey you
should make you should turn it into a
movie or something and he was like yeah
send me the book you know take a look at
it why not you know we were like oh wow
that worked like the weakest sales pitch
ever it as though he got his address I
sent him the book and and it pretty much
just took off from there
and we made the movie what you doing now
so now actually there's the funny part
about the movie is that Clint Eastwood
asked us to play ourselves in the movie
so we acted as ourselves and I was I
think that's the first time it's been
done since like Audie Murphy in the
1950s yeah so that was an amazing
experience I loved acting and so now I
pretty much moved down here to pursue
acting and try and get some more movies
and you know do something through some
stuff that I think would be cool and I
do a lot of speaking as well so I travel
all over the place give speeches you
know just try and inspire people
everything talked about not being a
bystander nowadays part two of a hell of
a thing people don't even know about it
Thanks amazing them yeah how's acting
it's tough yeah for sure I'm in class
it's not gonna come easy no waiting for
you I'm totally that's back-breaking
work acting there's a lot that goes into
it - and it's like did they were all day
all right 1214 hours
oh God you got my timing you love you
too tired
boom mm-hmm I'd do it again in the next
morning oh yeah man it's a real [ __ ]
job it's work man yeah if you really
want to do it I even got into that for a
while oh yeah I spent about six years on
sets
nobody ever saw me there but I was
around and but it's quite an experience
but it's worked it's the weirdest thing
to go audition for something though yeah
man that is so strange it's a weird
thing a lot harder than acting in my
opinion like three minutes yeah it's
just two people in a room and a little
camera yeah it's like the people talking
back - you are not putting any emphasis
on what they're saying it's like you
have to carry the whole thing and I'm
just like man it's just easier if we
just do the whole thing you know yeah
but I like it a lot though so I love
that stuff I love movies I grew up on
movies so dude I'm just so blown away
sane to me yes it's a stimulating life
thanks man it's amazing
Thanks well another thing I'm trying to
do right now is basically I'm in the
beginning phases of trying to create
this television show whether it's on
streaming or what and basically the
concept would be you know I'd be a
producer and a host on it and over the
course of the last three years I've met
a lot of other people with crazy stories
that have done amazing things right that
I've saved people or just really helped
someone else someone up if they were in
a bind or something like that and you
know me and my friends have been shown a
lot of gratitude we've been uplifted
praised you know a lot and you know just
to me there's there's too many people
out there that haven't received
recognition for something great they've
done and so the whole concept would be
is basically like me bringing their
stories to light and I'll call them like
unsung heroes or like the unsung whether
it's someone coming from the military
whether it's someone just off the street
who helps save somebody pulled someone
out of a car you know these things are
happening on a daily basis and you know
it's like 10 seconds on the news and
then people forget about it so I think
even just to like be able to immortalize
that for that person and their family
and have that legacy for them I think is
what motivates me to do it but hopefully
it happens hopefully it gets picked up
we'll see though it's tough it's out to
be seen more talk more try - I'm
definitely trying to get my toes wet out
here so we'll see what happens I got a
brother I got a sister my brothers the
older sisters the middle child I'm the
youngest and the baby the family and my
mom who lives up in Sacramento still
raised us all by herself so she's
another one of my heroes you know I'd do
anything for I love my mom you'd been in
an alcoholic he's in prison right now
actually up at Lompoc Lompoc yeah yeah
not too far from here he just actually
just went away about six months ago but
I think it's I think it's where he needs
to be right now to be honest yeah so I'm
not really tore up about it I love my
dad but he needs a reality check you
know so God works in mysterious ways may
yes he does no reason
nothing's just like you guys almost
didn't get on the train yeah yeah no
matter how much carnage would have been
done I know when when my buddy so when I
was helping mark and actually I forgot
about this part
my friend Alec grab dak loaded a new
round into it and then when check the
rest of the train to see if there's any
more terrorists and he went back there
and he said it was like five six cars
that were full of people were just empty
now and he goes back and they were just
crammed back there like cattle so if the
terrorists would have made it past us
which is like 30 40 people he would have
just been shooting fish in a barrel
yeah the only weapons on the train yeah
the only weapons on the train nobody can
stop him yeah except you guys yeah thank
God one of the best things you could
ever do is say someone's life so that's
the truth it's the most incredible story
I've ever heard
seriously really brain is even not
developed yet yeah go Spencer yeah
that's the tagline blazing glory oh this
is 22 I don't remember this cuz I think
I blacked out as I ran up to him but his
wife in an interview I can't find the
interview anymore though cuz it was
hilarious she goes yeah I'm looking you
know at my husband he's laying
underneath the seat and he's bleeding
and I see the terrorists coming in and
then I just see this big green shirt run
by and I just hear him scream
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
like man I don't remember saying that
but that's hilarious for America baby
what's up deep breath and observe the
situation message to chill out man yeah
yeah just chill man it's amazing [ __ ]
every fight I've been in I've never
thrown the first punch so I like to keep
it that way you know but if someone hits
you you got to do what you gotta do yes
you're right so is what it is [ __ ] dude
DHS sir at times yeah cuz my whole thing
cut and stabbed and a lot goes to yes no
this stablish shining come on hey
brother I'm cool you go to my
psychological damage you with a lot of
depression well that's definitely that's
one of the things with open heart
surgeries yeah yeah open heart surgery
it's like very it's the black the most
common symptom is depression well and
you know like definitely you know
everything everybody deals with it you
know at some point or regularly - but
the weird thing is is like I've just I
get uncomfortable when I'm going out now
like going out to a bar going out to a
club or something like that I feel like
I'm on I hate clubs well then you start
noticing that everybody has a knife on
them yeah everybody has something you
know and it's like man stay stay at home
and smoke some weed
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that but you gotta live
life to you do let it [ __ ] you can't let
it disable you hey all the power to you
if you want to be at the at the rave you
know whatever bro what the how's the
drug business on the service man people
drank my drugs drugged the whole drug
culture was very different at that time
I mean it was obviously the drugs were
there and in Vietnam all through Asia I
watching there talking with the
generation there talking with the
Vietnam War I got a guy have his gun his
shotgun and he's putting the weed
blowing smoking it the other guy yeah
I've had these deathless about shooting
the goddamn guy yeah that was in platoon
they do in Vietnam people usually lose
their mind in the war no I would not
usually no a lot of people don't know
nobody knows how they're gonna handle
combat so they get into it I mean I
don't care what they think just they
just don't know you can be the baddest
ass on in town and get in combat and you
just can't handle it or you could be the
milquetoast of town and get in there and
then be the big hero it's just it's
amazing how people react with and you
don't know when bombs are going off and
bulls yeah and a lot of ways it's so
much like happened with you you almost
don't even realize you're there I mean
you got things to do you got and the
fact that people are trying to kill your
bombs are going off it it's you're not
really afraid of that I mean you know
you know it's not a good thing but
you're doing other things you know just
like you're doing
you you got a problem you take care of
the problem and all this other stuff is
just it's like a wait like you're
watching a movie yeah definitely and if
you can't if you can't pull yourself
away if you're worried about me and
forget that this guy's in one taking
care of you the one up there if you lose
that contact and worry about yourself
you're in trouble you're really in
trouble in combat and then what one last
punch line for everybody watching this
podcast
don't forget the veterans you see and
don't forget those guys wearing the
uniforms that's why we can live like
we're living and we are living pretty
damn good and it's easy to lose lose the
bubble it really is because you get so
involved in what's going on in your town
and the state and the country and the
world and and just remember that it'd be
a hell of a lot worse if it weren't for
those people who had served and those
people we're in the suit and just don't
forget god bless them recognize them
acknowledge them because that's the core
of why we're why we are where we are
right now amen can I ask you a question
I know during the Vietnam War there
wasn't a lot appreciation for the people
coming back did you experience any of
that sure I was spat upon or was it was
horrible
the the people that were rioting against
the war for whatever reason and and when
I came back the first time it was very
early because I was in there pretty
early so the war had not the anti-war
actions that you've referred to really
were just starting and I mean I I never
was physically abused or challenged but
the these people screaming and shouting
just like you see on TV now was
signs and spitting at you and throwing
things at you you know you're a baby
killer why are you over there killing
and and that's kind of tough that's kind
of tough and that was the first time
second time I came back it was almost
worse but it was just because that was
about a year before the war was over and
people were resigned they didn't want to
have anything to do with the people
coming back from Vietnam like we had
caused the war we'd gone over there and
destroyed the country etc etc and it was
a tough time tough time for veterans
what I see now is much better you know
you know burl as far as veteran
appreciation good to know so you think
we're getting we're progressing and then
aspect I think so I think there's a lot
of it is social media which I am not
very astute at but because of that and
and a lot of it is commercial a lot of
commercial people are trying to make a
buck by appealing to the veteran thing
but that's and I'm not I'm not faulting
it that's good the more we can recognize
the veterans but there is a their
motivations behind recognizing now that
we're not there forty years ago then
there's still a lot of problems with the
vets homeless wait why I mean if you go
to the West Los Angeles VA yeah and you
go in there for five minutes you see
what the problem is right you know just
how it's horrible talk about that I mean
I just transfer it away from that
hospital that's where I was enrolled at
and it's just depressing in there man so
talk about the the protocol as a guy who
you're discharged from service and
you're back in civilian life and then
you know you have access to the VA you
know what's what how do you get a job
how do you get a house you come to have
any resources for you they they're
getting better so when you now when I
got out of the military I don't know if
it was like this for you Carlos you know
we had a program called called taps
where basically it prepares you to get
released from the military they make
they help you build a resume translate
what you did in the military to make it
applicable towards the civilian life and
things like that but it's I don't know
if it's as effective as it is I don't
really know but I would say where we
need to focus on the most is is there is
the health care system through the VA
because people are literally going in
there trying to get help and then they
go shoot themselves in their car in the
parking lot you know and it's just like
what are we doing is it because they are
so depressed or have so much mental
anguish it's hard to it's hard to tie
down there's a gazillion reasons and you
don't expect it there in a lot of yeah
emotionally one physically yeah pain
pains a lot of it there's no question
about that I use I use CBD I got lots of
pain I got pain places I didn't even
know I had places before yeah and and
and I'm certainly not to the degree of
people shooting themselves but yeah the
pain from wounds emotional pains from
trauma trauma and but as far as programs
I think certainly in the Marine Corps
and I'm sure it's true in the other
services but when you you're getting out
the local people really take care of you
they'll try to tell you where to go what
to do how to do it
and they really really care and again I
was blessed to be a marine and I don't
know somehow we seem to care longer and
broader than most services but the
services try but once you get out of
that little circle whatever it is if
it's out of the marine circle into this
area or out of the immediate Army or Air
Force people that let you go
I think individually then you're you're
kind of lost just I mean you're out of
the military and you're on your own and
you've lost lost three years four years
six years where your peer groups have
been working hopefully making money but
at least developing skills like still
learning life skills that are different
than military and stuff not to cut you
off Carlos but just get the thought
before I lose it I think especially like
as young men who join when they're 18 19
20 years old and they bypassed the
college route and I guess like the
normal route of things and you get out
whether you do 4 6 10 years you know and
you've lived this one life through the
military and I mean the military in my
opinion I went in a boy I came out a man
you know we were handle my stuff like I
could take care of myself I don't need
nobody and then it's like what you said
they can prepare you as much as possible
but then once you're out the circle it's
just you you know you're by yourself you
almost feel like very alone and there's
programs and things out and out there
like that there's there's a lot of
people doing good stuff so I don't want
to say that there's it's a complete
epidemic but it's still a struggle I
think no matter for who you are and what
you did in the military just to leave
the camaraderie of the military and just
be thrown out into the into the world
and it's a dog dog-eat-dog world out
there so the ocean of life yeah
and many guys are know this you know
through cannabis advocacy and all that
you know many vets are you go into the
VA and they're coming out with massive
prescriptions for opiates and highly
toxic powerful anti-inflammatories like
500 milligram ibuprofen [ __ ] like that
yeah and so access to cannabis is a big
issue for the veteran community no CBD
helping to deal with the physical pain
and you know alleviate the need for
opiates and all that stuff as well as
helping to treat the PTSD mm-hmm
you know so that's that's definitely a
big issue i don't i don't use cannabis
because i've got a disease in my legs
out of some people think it's from the
Aged Agent Orange that I was in early in
the war may or may not have been that
but I really really liked the cannabis
the feeling it gives you and what it
does for my pain but then I have trouble
walking I am because I'm a just and and
as much as I like the high and and the
and the feeling of not being in pain
it's I just can't afford to do it have
you tried not smoking it but doing the
sublingual drops yes yeah but it hits me
very quickly and very heavily and I just
I can't I don't even want to experiment
with it because yeah with with my
neuropathy I'm lucky lucky to get around
anyway so you stick with the CBD CBD for
it it's great oh yeah the copper copper
gel yeah the application what do you
call it the top topical then because
when I heard that several years ago
topical I had I thought it was something
from the tropics and
anyway no the topicals are excellent the
copper gel and the that ice and I use
that all the time and that really helps
I wish I could use cannabis I can't
yeah amen everybody's different yeah on
the white $0.50 thank you dude you're
the man and Carlos thank you thank you
both of you guys for your service and
everything big for our freedom I mean
that that's just it's an honor to do it
amen thank you and that's just really
doing work that's blindly going into
battle you know I mean you have a call
you believe in this cause and sometimes
these other people have a cause you may
not believe in this call but you you're
there for the [ __ ] show you know ya
guys got anything else you want to say
before we can anybody contact you or
anybody to contact y'all like Instagram
anybody ever get in touch did you get
your work out there for for like acting
or what yeah anything though people blow
a lot of smoke up at your ass they a lot
of empty promises out there true that's
what I always believed too but like you
said somebody came out Clements we came
somebody to come never give up never
look at like they're off it's over with
now no yeah definitely yeah that's do
you gotta have that to that you have
make you the person that you are thank
you no I'm not gonna give up his point I
already know it's like a deep core like
thing I have there's like I feel like
this is what I'm supposed to be doing I
wouldn't be going in this direction if I
didn't feel it in my gut but I just got
to put in a work can't give up like I'm
putting the work in man yep incredible
you're such a young guy
started off with this incredible life
man oh I just turned 26 [ __ ] bro man I
feel like I could talk to you guys
forever so you know me every 20 dude
you're just starting a mile I feel like
I've lived before yeah he's probably got
stories you hadn't had a chance to tell
you that's beautiful man I mean I don't
know what else to say that was amazing
thanks man well guys pick this out been
a great time man what an amazing episode
thank you guys again so Mikey for your
service for coming in here and honoring
us with this great pod interview Mike
thank you this is pretty awesome you
never know how you gonna act in war
right no acts of life you know we under
that pressure cook yeah that's right not
prepared okay I'm prepared you are when
the real thing comes down to the other
night though yeah that's it that's that
story of life your trainings gonna kick
in definitely so you better [ __ ] you
right so you better you better be
prepping in the meantime yeah no doubt
staying sharp staying on point
absolutely well for another great
episode of hotbox and I'm Evan Britton
I'm Mike - the dispenser and Carlos
we're out of here see ya
[Music]